foreign
just be who you are Selena
no one cares about what you're doing
it's about who I am
being okay with where I am
I am grateful to be alive
Selena Gomez was diagnosed with lupus
depression and anxiety
let me make a promise
I am going to stop living like this I
just want the free show how do I learn
how to Breeze my own breath again
[Music]
if anybody saw what I saw they wouldn't
have recognized her like the whole life
since I was a kid I've been working and
it wouldn't be like super famous but I
do know that if I'm here I have to use
that for good what's holding you back
from doing it
that I'm not good enough that's
something that I felt a lot of growing
up in this life you have to show people
empathy have a chance to give people
more than what you receive what makes me
happy is connection and it helps me get
out of my head do you know who this is
real mommy went to school with her
clearly I'm still here to use whatever I
have to help someone else
everything that I had gone through it's
gonna be there I'm just making it my
friend now I am happier and I'm in
control of my emotions and thoughts more
than I have ever been I think that you
are saving lives I know that you're
saving lives just so from a part of the
conversation you know
this is the beginning for me
[Music]
I love you ladies